donc là c'est un étage qui est dédié à
notre communauté afghane
vous avez une chambre sont des chambres
individuelles sont des petites chambres
ils sont 73 à vivre ici au monastère des
orantes un pakistanais 12 afghans et 59
tibétains des communautés totalement
différentes qui sont en france pour la
même raison
fuir la guerre dans leur pays d'origine
sonam et tibétaine et aujourd'hui elle
compte rester en france
si le tibet libéré je rentrerai mais
sinon je ne peux pas si je reviens là
bas je serai tué parce que là bas j'ai
pris part à des mouvements politiques
alors si je reviens je serai tué
tibétains et afghans cohabitent dans ce
centre d'hébergement soit comme
demandeurs d'asile ou réfugiés
statutaires
mais avec le même objectif rester en
france pour reconstruire leur vie
je dois rester ici je ne peux pas
rentrer dans mon pays ça n'est plus
possible je dois rester ici en france
j'étudie j'apprends le français j'ai
besoin d'apprendre c'est vraiment
important
apprendre le français l'une des
principales activités de ces réfugiés
tous les matins une association se rend
au monastère pour dispenser des cours
l'objectif c'est de les laisser devenir
autonome au plus vite
quoi qu'il puisse vraiment progresser
trouver du travail
s'intégrer plus facilement oui pour moi
le but ici bien sûr celui ci n'est pas
des gardés à bitam aeternam
c'est juste une période delà de leur vie
qui leur permet déjà de ceux de ce
reprendre d'essayer de de se poser pour
reconnaître un petit peu pour savoir ce
qu'ils veulent faire de leur avenir
nous avons donc des réfugiés statutaires
donc ça signifie dix ans a obtenu le
droit d'obtenir un titre de séjour de
visa en france est de travailler en
français c'est l'état qui choisit
ensuite de les déplacer dans un autre
logement ou une autre ville
pour l'instant les réfugiés qui vivent
ici sont totalement libres il participe
aux tâches ménagères et à des activités
mais peuvent sortir quand bon leur
semble sous réserve de pointer tous les
trois jours pour voir qu'on a fait 70 à
100 me en association et y habitent tous
dans la région et particulièrement à
ronel je pense que c'est un bon reflet
de ce que pense la population sur sur ce
monastère géré par l'association habitat
et humanisme ce centre d'hébergement est
avant tout un lieu de repos et
d'adaptation en plus des 60 bénévoles
pour les ateliers et cours de français
huit personnes travaillent ici pour
prodiguer un accompagnement humain et
administratifs une sorte de tremplin
social vers le renouvellement